[Applause]
thank you very much thank you
today Israel takes a big step towards
peace
young people across the Middle East are
ready for a more hopeful future and
governments throughout the region are
realizing that terrorism and Islamic
extremism are everyone's common enemy
yesterday I had the pleasure of meeting
with both the Prime Minister of Israel
and a man that's working very hard to
become the primary minister of Israel in
the longest-running election of all time
any chance of the blue and white party
and both leaders joined me to express
their support for this effort proving
that the State of Israel looking for
peace and that peace transcends politics
by any measure unmeasurable that's what
they want on my first trip overseas as
president I visited the Holy Land of
Israel I was deeply moved and amazed by
what this small country had achieved in
the face of overwhelming odds and
never-ending threats the State of Israel
comprises only a miniscule amount of
land in the Middle East and yet it has
become a thriving center of democracy
innovation culture and commerce Israel
is a light unto the world the hearts and
history of our people are woven together
the Land of Israel is an ancient home a
sacred place of worship and they solemn
promise to the Jewish people that we
will never again repeat history's
darkest hour
[Applause]
during my trip to Israel I also met with
Palestinian President Abbas in Bethlehem
I was saddened by the fate of the
Palestinian people they deserve a far
better life they deserve the chance to
achieve their extraordinary potential
Palestinians have been trapped in a
cycle of terrorism poverty and violence
exploited by those seeking to use them
as pawns to advance terrorism and
extremism I returned from my visit
determined to find a constructive path
and it's got to be a very powerful path
forward in the israeli-palestinian
conflict to further this effort I also
met with President Abbas at the White
House forging peace between Israelis and
Palestinians may be the most difficult
challenge of all all prior
administration's from President Lyndon
Johnson have tried and bitterly failed
but I was not elected to do small things
or shy away from big problems
it's been a long and very arduous
process to arrive at this moment on
Sunday I delivered to Prime Minister
Netanyahu my vision for peace prosperity
and a brighter future for the Israelis
and Palestinians this vision for peace
is fundamentally different from past
proposals in the past even the most
well-intentioned plans were light on
factual details and heavy on conceptual
frameworks by contrast our plan is 80
pages and as the most detailed proposal
ever put forward by far as I have seen
throughout my long career as a dealmaker
complex problems require nuanced
fact-based remedies that is why our
proposal provides precise technical
solutions to make Israelis Palestinians
and the region safer and much more
prosperous my vision presents a win-win
opportunity for both sides a realistic
two-state solution that resolves the
risk of Palestinian statehood to
Israel's security today Israel has taken
a giant step toward peace yesterday
Prime Minister Netanyahu informed me
that he is willing to endorse the vision
as the basis for direct negotiations and
I will say the general also endorsed and
very strongly with the Palestinians a
historic breakthrough and likewise we
have really a situation having to do
with a race that is taking place right
now it will end and we have the support
and it's very important to say this of
both parties and almost all people in
Israel they want peace and they want
peace badly
this is the first time Israel has
authorized the release of a conceptual
map illustrating the territorial
compromises it's willing to make for the
cause of peace and they've gone a long
way this is an unprecedented and highly
significant development mr. prime
minister thank you for having the
courage to take this bold step forward
[Applause]
[Applause]
and bebe we have a lot of powerful
people in this one a lot of the people
that can help make it work so that's
quite a thunderous applause thank you
very much
thank you we will form a joint committee
with Israel to convert the conceptual
map into a more detailed and calibrated
rendering so that recognition can be
immediately achieved we will also work
to create a contiguous territory within
the future Palestinian state for when
the conditions for statehood are met
including the firm rejection of
terrorism
[Applause]
under this vision Jerusalem will remain
Israel's undivided very important
undivided capital
[Applause]
but that's no big deal
because I've already done that for you
right we've already done that but that's
okay it's going to remain that way and
the United States will recognize Israeli
sovereignty over the territory that my
vision provides to be part of the State
of Israel very important and crucially
the proposed transition to a two-state
solution will present no incremental
security risk to the State of Israel
whatsoever we will not allow a return to
the days of bloodshed bus bombings
nightclub attacks and relentless terror
won't be allowed peace requires
compromise but we will never ask Israel
to compromise its security can't do them
as everyone knows I have done a lot for
Israel moving the United States Embassy
to Jerusalem
recognizing recognizing the Golan
Heights
and frankly perhaps most importantly
getting out of the terrible Iran nuclear
deal
[Applause]
there's a lot of spirit in this room
it's true you don't see it often you
don't see it often therefore it is only
reasonable that I have to do a lot for
the Palestinians or it just wouldn't be
fair you know don't clap for that okay
but it's true it wouldn't be fair
I want this deal to be a great deal for
the Palestinians it has to me today's
agreement is a historic opportunity for
the Palestinians to finally achieve an
independent state of their very own
after 70 years of little progress this
could be the last opportunity they will
ever have and last for a lot of reasons
we'll never have a team like we have
right now we have a team of people that
love the United States and they love
Israel and they are very smart and very
very committed from your ambassador
David Friedman
you Jason and avi and Jarrod
[Applause]
and they're all great deal makers and
they also understand the other side and
they want the other side to do well
because that's the sign of a great deal
and they understand that and I just
appreciate all of our hard work you put
in and so many of your other friends and
of course our great Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo
[Applause]
that's impressive that was very
impressive
that reporter couldn't have done too
good a job on you yesterday I think you
did a good job on her actually that's
good thank you Mike great Barry are you
running for Senate I guess the answer's
no after that they all want him to
Kansas great state they want him to but
you're doing a great job don't move the
Palestinian people have grown
distrustful
after years of unfulfilled promises so
true yet I know they are ready to escape
their tragic past and realize a great
destiny but we must break free of
yesterday's failed approaches this map
will more than double the Palestinian
territory and provide a Palestinian
capital in eastern Jerusalem where
America will proudly open an embassy no
Palestinians or Israelis will be
uprooted from their homes
Israel will work closely with a
wonderful person a wonderful man the
king of Jordan to ensure that the status
quo of the Temple Mount is preserved and
strong measures are taken to ensure that
all Muslims who wish to visit peacefully
and pray at the AL aqua mosque will be
able to do so this is a major statement
this is a major important importance and
at the same time our vision will deliver
a massive commercial investment of 50
billion dollars into the new Palestinian
state you have many many countries that
want to partake in this and many of them
are surrounding they all want this to
happen virtually every one of them want
this to happen and I think Bibi you know
that very well you're gonna have
tremendous support from your neighbors
and beyond your neighbors over the next
10 years if executed well 1 million
great new Palestinian jobs will be
created their poverty rate will be cut
in half and their poverty rate is
unacceptable now and only getting worse
their GDP will double and triple and
much-needed hope joy opportunity and
prosperity will finally arrive for the
Palestinian people our vision will end
the cycle of Palestinian dependency upon
charity and foreign aid they will be
doing phenomenally all by themselves
they are very very capable people
and we will help by empowering the
Palestinians to thrive on their own
Palestinians will be able to seize the
new future with dignity self-sufficiency
and national pride to ensure a
successful Palestinian state we are
asking the Palestinians to meet the
challenges of peaceful coexistence this
includes adopting basic laws enshrining
Human Rights protecting against
financial and political corruption
stopping the malign activities of Hamas
Islamic Jihad and other enemies of peace
ending the incitement of hatred against
Israel so important and permanently
halting the financial compensation to
terrorists
[Applause]
and perhaps most importantly my vision
gives the Palestinians the time needed
to rise up and meet the challenges of
statehood I sent a letter today to
President Abbas I explained to him that
the territory allocated for his new
state will remain open and undeveloped
for a period of four years during this
time Palestinians can use all
appropriate deliberation to study the
deal negotiate with Israel achieve the
criteria for statehood and become a
truly independent and wonderful State
President Abbas I want you to know that
if you choose the path to peace America
and many other countries will we will be
there we will be there to help you in so
many different ways and we will be there
every step of the way we will be there
to help
in other words for the first time in
many many decades I can say it will work
it's going to work if they do this it
will work your response to this historic
opportunity will show the world to what
extent you are ready to lead the
Palestinian people to statehood the
Middle East is changing rapidly on my
first trip aboard as president I
traveled to Saudi Arabia to discuss our
shared priorities with the 54 leaders of
the Muslim and Arab countries I made
clear that all civilized nations share
the same goals stamping out extremism
creating opportunity for the region's
youth and we have to take care of the
region's youth the region's youth is
growing up with no hope we have to take
care of the region's youth and existing
in harmony with one's neighbors since
that time immense progress has been made
a growing number of nations have taken
strong stands against terrorism and
radicalization you see it thanks to the
courage of US forces the ISIS
territorial Caliphate one hundred
percent not ninety five percent not 99
or any other percent 100 percent of
their Caliphate Isis is destroyed and
it's savage leader al Baghdadi is now
dead
and I want to thank we have some more
great senators and congressmen and women
here and I want to thank you all for the
tremendous help thank you very much Jim
Ted everybody's doing
leader leader thank you mark thank you
great people these are great people they
work so hard and they love this country
the Iranian regime is isolated and
weakened greatly we eliminated
Hassam Salamone the world's top
[Applause]
and as you know he was with the head of
Hezbollah I don't think they were up to
anything good I don't think so he ran an
organization called Jerusalem liberation
forces and used his hatred total severe
hatred of Israel as a rallying cry to
divert attention from the incompetence
and shortcomings of his government he
falsely promoted the sinister notion
that a free Jerusalem
we must really be at war with Israel so
to have it free we have to be at war
with Israel and he said it very very
powerfully in fact it's been in this
false war that Israel really the enemies
of peace have used that they just used
it as an excuse to divide and totally
oppress the Middle East in truth
Jerusalem is liberated
Jerusalem is a safe open democratic city
that welcomes people of all faiths and
all places it is time for the Muslim
world to fix the mistake it made in 1948
when it chose to attack instead of
recognize the new State of Israel
it's time
[Applause]
since then the amount of needless
bloodshed and squandered opportunities
so many squandered opportunities in the
name of senseless causes is beyond
measure the Palestinians have been the
primary pawn in this regional
adventurism and it's time for this sad
chapter in history to end and quickly
end now it's never too late for
courageous leaders to set a new course
to pursue what is right to change the
future only for the better America is
prepared to work with all parties on our
vision so many other countries are
willing ready and able to work with us
I've spoken to many of them I cannot
believe the amount of support this
morning has I cannot believe it I have
been called by leaders Boris called so
many called and they're all saying
whatever we can do to help they all want
to see it happen
but America cannot care more about peace
than the stakeholders in the region
there are many Muslims who never visited
a laksa and many Christians and Jews who
never visited the holy sites in the West
Bank described so vividly in the Bible
my vision will change that are majestic
biblical heritage will be able to live
breathe and flourish in modern times all
humanity should be able to enjoy the
glories of the Holy Land this part of
the world is forever connected to the
human soul and the human spirit
these ancient land should not be symbols
of conflict but eternal symbols of peace
thank you again for all of the work
you've all done and all of these
incredible honored guests for being here
and in particular I want to thank Prime
Minister Netanyahu I also want to thank
Amon Bahrain and the United Arab
Emirates for the incredible work they've
done helping us with so much and sending
their ambassadors to be with us today
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
please give our regards America's
partnerships in the region have never
been greater and our alliance with the
State of Israel has never ever been
stronger than it is today together we
can bring about a new dawn in the Middle
East and I would now again just like to
thank everybody and a very special group
of people an incredible group of people
so many have been with us on this
journey right from the beginning and
we're getting there it's they say it's
the toughest deal ever to make in
business one I have a tough deal people
would say this is tougher than the
Israelis and the Palestinians they used
it as an excuse meaning that was always
the standard actually there's nothing
tougher than this one but we have to get
it done we have an obligation to
humanity to get it done
so I would now like to introduce the
Prime Minister of Israel who's worked so
hard on this Benjamin Netanyahu thank
you
[Applause]
in the middle-east we drink water before
a long voyage this is an extraordinary
voyage President Trump Donald I'm
honored to be here today along with my
wife Sarah ministerial Yves Lavigne
ambassador Ron Dermer Ron thank you for
everything you've been doing
National Security Adviser advisor mayor
Ben Shabbat thank you to mayor and our
entire delegation we are honored to be
here with you mr. president with
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo we
applaud you Mike secretary of the
Treasury Steve minuchin national
security adviser robert o'brien
America's UN Ambassador Kelly craft
Jared Kushner and Ivanka it's good to
see you both
[Applause]
it's good to see the unfailingly
energetic and optimistic ambassador
David Friedman Jason Greenblatt I'll be
Berkowitz Brian hook and the rest of
your exceptional piece pan mr. president
is good to be here with the other
distinguished ladies and gentlemen of
your administration with senators and
members of Congress who are Israel's
greatest friends on Capitol Hill thank
you
[Applause]
with the ambassadors of the United Arab
Emirates Bahrain and Oman what a
pleasure to see you here and what a sign
it portends I was going to say of the
future what I signed it pretends of the
present to all of you and to the many
distinguished other distinguished guests
who are here today this is a historic
day and it recalls another historic day
we remember May 14th 1948 because on
that day
President Truman became the first world
leader to recognize the State of Israel
after our first Prime Minister David
ben-gurion declared our independence
that day chartered a brilliant future
mr. president I believe that down the
decades and perhaps down the centuries
we will also remember January 28th 2020
because on this day you became the first
world leader to recognize Israel's
sovereignty over areas in Judea and
Samaria that are vital to our security
and central to our heritage
[Applause]
and on this day you too
have charted a brilliant future a
brilliant future for Israelis
Palestinians and the region by
presenting a realistic path to a durable
peace since the moment of its birth
Israel is yearned for peace with our
Palestinian neighbors and peace with a
broader Arab world for decades that
peace has proved elusive despite so many
well-intentioned plans one after the
other they failed why did they fail they
failed because they did not strike the
right balance between Israel's vital
security and national interests and the
Palestinians aspirations for
self-determination too many plans tried
to pressure Israel to withdraw from
vital territory like the Jordan Valley
but you mr. president
you recognized that Israel must have
sovereignty in the Jordan Valley and the
other in other strategic areas of Judea
and Samaria rather than pay easy lip
service to Israel's security and simply
shut your eyes hope for the best
you recognize that Israel must have
sovereignty in places that enable Israel
to defend itself by itself
[Applause]
for too long far too long the very heart
of the Land of Israel where our
patriarch sprayed our prophets preached
and our kings ruled has been
outrageously branded as illegally
occupied territory well today mr.
president you are puncturing this big
lie
you are recognizing Israel sovereignty
over all the Jewish communities in Judea
and Samaria large and small alike these
as the distinguished pastors who are
here know very well these are places
inscribed in the pages of the Bible
these are places carved into the bedrock
of our common civilization the sacred
tomb in Hebron where the fathers and
mothers of the Jewish people are buried
Bethel where Jacob dreamed of a ladder
ascending to the heavens
she law where the Ark of the Covenant
that held the Ten Commandments for 10th
century for 10th century for a sorry for
centuries that's what happened in Shiloh
thanks to you mr. president these areas
and so many others that for millennia
have been etched in the soul of the
Jewish people and inspired the
imaginations of millions of people
around the world and across the world
these areas will now be recognized by
the United States as a permanent part of
the Jewish state
[Applause]
mr. president because of this historic
recognition and because I believe your
peace plan strikes the right balance
where other plans have failed I've
agreed to negotiate peace with the
Palestinians on the basis of your peace
plan it's a great plan for Israel it's a
great plan for peace frankly mr.
president given all that you have
already done for Israel I'm not
surprised you have been the greatest
friend that Israel has ever had in the
White House
[Applause]
frankly though we've had some great
outstanding friends in these holes it's
not even close Yura Stark decisions to
recognize Jerusalem as Israel's capital
to recognize Israel's sovereignty over
the Golan Heights to reaffirm Israel's
legal claims in Judea and Samaria to
stand up to Iran to pull out of that
dangerous Iran deal to confront confront
is not the word to eliminate Qasem
Soleimani to support and encourage
unbelievable cooperation between Israel
and the United States in the military
and strategic and intelligence fields
all this bear testament to the
friendship and depth of your leadership
and commitment to Israel from our very
first meeting here in the White House
three years ago you repeatedly made
clear your commitment to help Israel
achieve peace with the Palestinians and
peace with the rest of the Arab world
mr. president I share that commitment
and I look forward to working with you
to achieve a peace that will protect
Israel's security provide the
Palestinians with dignity and their own
national life and improve Israel's
relations with the Arab world your peace
plan advances all these goals first it
addresses the root cause of the conflict
the incident by insisting that the
Palestinians will finally have to
recognize Israel as the Jewish state
[Applause]
second it stipulates that Israel will
retain security control in the entire
area west of the Jordan River thereby
giving Israel a permanent eastern border
a permanent eastern border to defend
ourselves across our longest border this
is something we've long to have we now
have such a recognized boundary third
your plan calls for Hamas to be disarmed
and for Gaza to be demilitarized fourth
it makes clear that the Palestinian
refugee problem must be solved outside
the State of Israel fifth it calls for
our ancient capital Jerusalem to remain
united under Israel's sovereignty and of
course ensures that religious sites
remain accessible to all faiths and it
maintains the status quo on the Temple
Mount
six your plan does not uproot anyone
from their homes Israelis and
Palestinians alike instead it proposes
innovative solutions whereby Israelis
will be connected to Israel and whereby
Palestinians will also be connected to
one another this is that helps if you
have these real estate people you know
they they can come up with they can come
up with things normal human beings don't
think about and they have mr. president
Israel wants the Palestinians to have a
better life we want them to have a
future of national dignity prosperity
and hope your peace plan offers the
Palestinians such a future your peace
plan offers the Palestinians a pathway
to a future state I know that it may
take them a very long time to reach the
end of that path it may even take them
very long time to get to the beginning
of that path but if the Palestinians are
genuinely prepared to take that path if
they're genuinely prepared to make peace
with the Jewish States and if they agree
to abide by all the conditions you have
put forward in your plan Israel will be
there Israel would be prepared to
negotiate peace right away regardless of
the Palestinian decision Israel will
preserve the path of peace in the coming
years for at least four years Israel
will maintain the status quo in areas
that your plan does not designate as
being part of Israel in the future at
the same time Israel will apply its laws
to the Jordan Valley to all the Jewish
communities in Judea and Samaria and to
other areas that your plan designates as
part of Israel in which the United
States has agreed to recognize as part
of Israel I like this decision will
protect Israel's security ensure
Israel's national interests and leave
open the possibility of a political
settlement with the Palestinians in the
coming years mr. president and I hope
the Palestinians embrace your vision of
peace embrace the plan that you and your
team and us worked so hard to achieve
I hope that they seize the opportunity
offered by your sweeping economic plan
I've read it it takes enormous talent to
reject 50 billion dollars worth of
investment I know what that does to an
economy I know what it will do to
Palestinian lives I know what it will do
to the youth of the region I hope that
the Palestinians embraced
and build with Israel a future of
prosperity and peace I also hope that
our other Arab neighbors embrace your
vision and forge a path of
reconciliation with Israel that can
create for all of us a brilliant future
mr. president I want to congratulate
your fantastic team there's no other
word your fantastic piece T for all
their work
Jason Greenblatt thank you Jason for the
terrific job you did as America's peace
envoy for nearly three years
avi Berkowitz thank you for stepping out
Thank You Ali for stepping out from your
important behind the roles seen behind
the scenes role and Abele working in
those past few months to get this plan
done ambassador David Friedman thank you
Dave
thank you for your essential
contribution to this effort and for the
terrific job you do every day
to strengthen the great alliance between
Israel and America and Jared Kushner
without your wisdom your persistence
your resolve this day would have never
come
I know how much the Jewish future means
to you and to your family well Jared
today you will help secure that future
the Jews state owes you and it owes
President Trump an eternal debt of
gratitude mr. president on that historic
day of May 14th 1948 both David
ben-gurion
and President Truman's had a fateful
decision to make many argued that
ben-gurion should not declare Israel's
independence many argued that President
Truman should not recognize the Jewish
state but both leaders understood the
magnitude of the hour they seized the
moment and they changed history like you
mr. president I understand the magnitude
of this moment with you mr. president
I'm prepared to seize the moment and
change history I know that there'll be
opposition there's always opposition I
know there'll be many obstacles along
the way much criticism but we have an
old Jewish saying if not now when and if
not us who in law shall a Matai in law
an afternoon as me mr. president your
deal of the century is the opportunity
of the century and rest assured Israel
will not miss this opportunity mr.
Donald Israel is blessed to have your
friendship and your powerful leadership
and Israel is blessed to have the
friendship of the greatest power and
earth the United States of America may
God bless america
may god bless israel and may god bless
us all with security prosperity and
peace thank you
[Applause]